I don't feel like people see Oakland or
our people for who they really are
everybody sees us as criminals and with
threats
put some logic raise your hand there's
any animosity towards the police in this
room right now don't be afraid to do it
we expect it how do you think the police
view you boom a threat you know how to
let they fear us in some ways that's why
in my videos we see they just come down
the first thing they do is draw
how many of you have a friend or
relative who's lost their lives to
violence here at Oakland how many oh my
god
I'm doing good how about shoes I'm
hanging you better hurry up you better
get there the class before I do I got
some stuff come see me after school as a
system we're like we have to look if
we're suspending far too many black boys
what do we need to do what do we need to
do differently
african-american males are located in
the environment that doesn't have their
best interests in mind and you have to
have very targeted strategies for those
students that are furthest away from
opportunity
what comic-book did I relate Malcolm and
Martin to actually it takes place in the
civil rights movement right so you got
Professor X who believes what everyone
is equal same idea lass okay when we
first started a lot of our Kings when we
were doing listening campaigns were
sharing that they didn't have access to
african-american men and so having an
african-american male teacher during the
school day Monday through Friday is just
an immediate winner in order for a
student to thrive they have to know that
they can speak freely it feels good to
them that somebody's holding them
accountable
grunt here is amazing I love Oakland I
grew up in a single-parent household my
mom worked hard to to make sure that I
had a good life it would be a whole
bunch of times where I think that here
in Oakland I could have just gave up I
could have quit but she wasn't allowed
to have him I was kind of forced into
the class because its 10th grade I
wasn't really doing so well if I kept
getting in Cindy's I wasn't gonna be
able to go to college Rick and I had
this small little connection and
closeness I told him I said hey over the
summer if you need anything call me
he called me maybe a couple weeks later
but then he tells me so my mom's not
doing so hot then about a week and a
half later calls me back and he says my
mom's past at that point I was so rude
and disrespectful I don't think I even
had anybody else to call I asked him one
simple question I said what are you
gonna do how are you gonna live your
mother's legacy
they mention you here in this article I
was almost kicked out in high school I
thought I was always going to be able to
get away with stuff and not have
consequences AJ was a hothead really
smart great potential it has a real fire
he had a real passion and he just needed
to be heard mr. Hancock was like there's
gonna be a lot of opportunities that
pass you because you never want to
listen to nobody people always said I
had potential but never put me in a
situation where I can see that for
myself most of all of these letters are
just letting me know I've been accepted
into all of these schools some of them
are scholarship informations my major
that I'm a study is nursing I like
helping people because I know how it
feels when you're down and out and you
can always use that extra boost I
basically had nothing I felt like I put
a lot of stress on my mom it was time
for me to change I don't know how he did
it but going from underperforming to
being a 3.8 GPA student says that I got
an a potential I'm a king I've been
living with my sister since my mom died
and my niece it's nice to have her
around and I can start off by helping
her he wants to defeat the stereotype
that's often put on young brothers that
are here in Oakland what makes me want
to get out of Oakland so bad it was just
I'm tired of seeing a lot of people
being murdered over stupid things I
don't want that to be my story whatever
I obtain and when I get older I'm gonna
come back to okay
part of being a leader is being able to
tell your story
cuz when you tell your story you connect
with other people and when you connect
with other people what happens you feel
relationships now you talked about how
you like school is it hard for you like
kind of hard people then whatever stop
me from getting my education just make
sure that the people you hang around is
the people that you know how to sound
kamikaze so I guess we post some fill in
this little book
alright talk to me tell me well because
Europe he is little ya kill Jeff Hardy
Boys general children market women
brother to like southern importers
that's what I'm talking about
thank you I really made a connection
with him and I plan on being his
mentor's and I plan on working with him
from now on
today is tryouts and on Wednesday I find
out 200 the team I've been playing
vegetables is my freshman here and I
really want to hope so and made it just
they gave me the courage to do it and to
try it for me hoop for my mom so you
know how about hopeless you come watch
me
you can't really do nothing by yourself
you know you need people around you need
supporters
here's your focus right now the schools
that you want to go to and in financial
aid scholarship stuff like that let's
take it back two years ago did you see
yourself here in this position to where
all these schools are pulling you in
saying hey come on I really think I was
on better college actually ever I'll be
the first one some be the first
generation so I thought I just saw right
along with the fam not going to college
I feel like I'm making the right
decision
you